this is dreamscaperers girth over the
socket to me okay you are really
something's bad happening here and to me
we clear no no stop no you really need
to you're taking that off but next week
that's just you know what you're sucking
the fun out of this it's just creepy now
it was fun at first even debatably not
but now it's just becoming very
unsettling and boy it somebody really
grumpy I'm just gonna pretend you're not
here right now
uh this is dreamscaperers is skipper I
can't say the title of this but big
shock I can't do English well now
yes especially just when you wear those
okay okay
so if this is an episode I really like
this one lots of stuff gonna the
introduction of bill cipher that
triangle that we always see at the
beginning like I was awesome yes a major
major character we just know he's like
one of the most dangerous entities out
there one of the most dangerous things
gideon summons him to go inside Stan's
mine to get the combination get the deed
to the mystery shack so our heroes have
to go in they have to follow him and try
to see if they can stop him forgave the
combination
Mabel gets her I just combed the gem
boys season
yeah the like there was no synthesized
music it's which I don't think there was
I try to think was there ever a show in
the 80s that like it was like gem before
boy it's dard boys you don't think there
was but it's like they give the idea
vaguely animes to me within that 80's
sort of I don't maybe it's a combination
of everything but yeah that's where am i
falling it was when they came back I was
just like yes ya know cuz they made a
quick intro in like why the early
episodes and yeah we see them here so
yeah I did pick up on the fact that the
cypher calls them question mark triangle
no no question right now question mark
our entry yeah and those are Venables
yeah yeah on the in the opening there's
this giant and it's also what like they
kind of would cause like zoo said the
question mark and dipper has the pine
yeah it's all what they wear and Mabel
has a shooting star so what are some
when they're stuff like glasses are on
there that's probably stay so then that
makes a question what's giddy he's got
to be one of the symbols and I I wasn't
looking for that this person I've seen
it so but now them doesn't have that
well could be III know that the hair
like I think Wendy's had if it's in the
book yeah if it's in the book don't you
think getting whatever symbol then he's
using one of the books always well one
would thing but I'm not sure I know it's
like a llama on there too there's a few
other things so no but the interest it
is that there's a couple things I notice
in this one um uh let's see uh just that
Muslim arches joke say hey you know it
was empty said Tia makes a little Gideon
um gr f--
which it obviously is there are yeah but
I'm wondering that today immediate
reference honestly it's obviously you
know nerve there satirizing but it's a
yeah it sounds like what a pinky are you
pondering what I'm pondering I think so
brain but why does not need a why uh
that dead possum is still in the kitchen
while of the dead possum in the kitchen
uh okay other things i knows on top of
the building on stands my there's
another code it looks like a jumble of
letters but again i haven't decoded it
the decoding at the end credits is just
to be continued in this one it just says
to be continued um I love you freakin
jag-offs I love the bid where he opens
the vending machine is just like I'll
bet nobody ever knew about this secret
here this is like an whatever cuz if I
close the door like now
oh the when he's summoning a away
summoning bill cipher there's actually
eyes in the trees they're surrounding
him which is interesting they look like
just wrinkles in tree but they're
actually eyes shaped very much like his
eye
um the yeah question mark pine tree we
got that um yeah so it's definitely oh
the okay when he says he says Stan and
he remembers me he says I have history
with him and he goes through these
images one of them is kind of like this
it's this symbol that I realize if I'm
right there's a flag in the background I
want to say like where he watches TV
that looks very much like this symbol it
almost looks like a state flag or
something but it's not a obviously know
state symbol or anything uh and yeah now
I'm starting to wonder if that's
anything um also the rug they move where
like stand hid stuff or whatever has an
interesting symbol on to so I not a ton
of answers but at the same time now you
know whenever you see I revolved the
world of Stan's brain with the way they
washed it out did a black and white with
all the old wood yeah a weird sort
memories were like goes up to me it's
like he's watching a black and white
television set and I love the fact that
maples hamster balls came back yes that
was amazing that the kittens professor
great yeah they do I hello there this is
kittens for fairness the only thing I
was kind of just raised whyever going
really is when stances all that
apparently says all the terrible stuff
about dipper it's like that's what they
used to say about me I'm like really we
did that Amy it's like you know what the
message is gonna be edits by it's
actually not a bad message you know to
sort of toughen up and be stronger fight
back you know you're just so critical
but I think the whole idea that like
okay the whole idea that you're going to
like do this thing where it's like you
miss here something is bad enough but
when it's so forced like you know you're
a loser you're a G you'll never amount
to anything that's what they all said
about me is just like
I cringe whenever I hear that I was just
like this is so far it's a show for
ten-year-old but it's
or it's so much more and when that
happens it reminds me it's a show for 10
year-olds out like a know you were
you're the chosen one you still are you
HS and Kane here but most of them kind
of been like a funny Citizen Kane with
you know dinosaurs and bill cipher no I
I don't recall grunkle Stan sitting
there in bed saying rose brows Maude
it's a slide true story and I just saved
ya like two hours it's a slice that
would be like
grunkle Stan's a citizen came um said
this was our first I think this is our
first to be continued episode leading
into the Whitney's busted through the
mystery shack sign I swear to God I was
like no which was already falling apart
anyway yeah but I'm just like it was
like oh it's real like oh uh yeah
no I because that's what I thought too I
like when they say don't worry it's
still part of a dream right I like it
you can't think about like oh okay this
is just cuz you know going into the next
episode like all the people pricing that
all we know it's just a dream and stuff
but like you said so much more
heartbreaking and shattering when you
know it's I'm just have grown to love
the mystery shack so no well for me I I
don't think they like I think they
damaged it a little bit more I camera if
they actually I don't know they don't
destroy the whole thing they can't
destroy the whole thing but it is one of
those things where I'm like wait did
that one hole in the roof yeah I mean
device one of those things where I'm
just like wait did that one room before
they snuck in you know like get damaged
because I want to know the answers to
them stuff so yeah there is Canada's big
shock when you see something you're so
used to seeing destroyed it's like wait
do we lose an answer there did we lose
something important it's like wait
they're they're writing it they can do
whatever they want but it's like I like
a show where you get that invested like
you said we see the sign destroyed
you're like oh but was there was a
something hidden in there that I bet
stews yeah I think the thing I really
liked about this episode in particular
in the show in general is that again
it's a team effort
like dipper may find out yeah protecting
him but the second dipper told Mabel it
was like just imagination unleash
like oh we can do that BAM kittens
refills
I like how I like how Seuss uses the the
Care Bears - yeah colourful belly stare
so um oh God in that memory where a
grunkle Stan was like eating the graham
cracker with his stomach so yeah so we
finally have those cipher in the show
another great villain both very funny
and I am very threatening very
intimidating uh and if people finally
know what that triangle at the opening
is so well kind of I mean we don't
exactly know what he is but we have he
has a Dame down he's a charming triangle
what more do you need to know what more
do you need to know the ice ice ice ice
Alize mod isosceles isosceles I thought
I can't say the title so it doesn't
matter um but all Greek to me ah sock